there is a trade war going on between
America and China which is dominated
global politics and a lot of that is to
do with more traditional goods like cars
or soybeans but actually quite a lot of
attentions being paid to semiconductors
as well so semiconductors are a vital
ingredient in computer chips they have
electrical characteristics that make the
chips work if you look in your car
you'll find not just one but probably
dozens of different computers your
smartphone obviously in your pocket
whenever you do anything with your bank
that transaction below must certainly be
handled electronically and they're only
going to become more common as computers
spread further and further into modern
life America is really the dominant
player of the top 15 biggest companies
none of them are Chinese China does have
an industry but a lot of it is dependent
on imports so semiconductor imports
actually cost it more than oil and a lot
of what it imports are components that
then go into finished goods so you think
of things like your iPhone which is
assembled in China but all of the
designs for the chips and the chips
themselves come from outside
semiconductors are important really for
two reasons
one is economic and they underlie huge
parts of the global economy so the
entire ecommerce industry for instance
was had revenues of about two trillion
dollars a year would be impossible
without semiconductors there's also a
national security angle in America in
particular has always seen its lead in
this technology as a vital national
security asset and America's military
was actually one of the earliest and
biggest customers for silicon valley's
chips and even these days you know
armies like everything else for becoming
increasingly digital and semiconductors
are vital to make that happen
in order to build up its domestic
industry China's willing to spend a lot
of money so it's established a
investment fund designed to boost the
local industry and it's capitalized that
with a hundred and fifty billion dollars
and it's made semiconductors one of the
priority areas in It's Made in China
2025 initiative which is a general
attempt to boost manufacturing across
the country America sees semiconductors
as a strategic good so it's quite
worried by China's attempts to build up
a domestic industry earlier this year
America forbade its companies from
selling chips and intellectual property
to ZTE which is a Chinese maker of
smartphones and telecom equipment and
because it's dependent on American chips
the company was pushed to the brink of
bankruptcy almost overnight and was only
saved at the last minute when Trump
decided to rescind the ban the ZTE
affair proved two things one was that
America's technological lead translates
into political power it can use this
lead to frustrate Chinese ambitions but
it also made it very clear to China just
how dependent their companies are on
American products there are several ways
in which America could respond to this
the first might be to try and work with
its allies countries like South Korea
Japan Taiwan which have big chip
manufacturing industries of their own to
make sure that China doesn't get an
unnecessary leg up but also to try and
work to establish standards so that both
sides can start to trust each other's
products a little bit more a second idea
is innovation is to try to push the
cutting edge out further to run faster
to stay ahead of China in the race
rather than trying to hobble the Chinese
but I think the final thing America
should do as well is just to prepare for
a world in which China is more of a
power in this industry and does have
more of an influence over the digital
economy I think it can probably try to
slow China down I'm not sure that it can
prevent it entirely and of course trying
to do that would be quite an aggressive
move that would also do quite a lot of
damage potentially to a really vital
industry that underpins the entire
global economy
you